[Music]
thank you
now let's talk about the BBC and the
Apparently never-ending question of bias
within the British Broadcasting
Corporation I'm joined Now by Rod little
uh the much loved the great spectator
columnist uh and we're going to be
talking about he's just stopped abusing
us I should say about the quality of our
set here at spectator TV having worked
at the BBC Rod uh you're used to higher
standards of broadcasting
um but in your column this week you talk
about a possible New Direction for the
BBC
um based on the fact that Newsnight
seems to have dropped its bias which you
describe uh brilliantly as a kind of
broadcasted Hampstead Garden suburbs
slip page of the Guardian uh that was
what it was in its previous Incarnation
um it has seemed to have changed
Direction and you're saying it's better
as a result
and it's much better uh instead of
having Four Women debating and being
very miserable with each other uh uh
especially about right-wing people and
the Tories uh there's now a kind of
breadth to the interviews who
occasionally indeed see a man
um uh on them
um uh and and uh I think you know Mark
Urban particularly
um is very very even-handed you know
I've heard a number of interviews where
the interviewee has been uh quizzed from
both left and right
um which which is kind of the way it's
meant to be it's it's become sharper in
its coverage of politics
um it's more intelligent rather than a
kind of scream Fest of of outrage and
abuse and I would put that down to a
change of editor and a change of
presenters
which it's I I think will come as no
surprise to your to your uh to your
viewers which is that uh as we ran who
was the editor uh has left and so has
the presenter Emily madeless and so has
Lewis Noel or whatever he's called
they've all gone uh and so the so the
program is becoming measurably better I
mean they need to deal with their
production team which when I met them
seemed to be a convocation of
perpetually uh uh triggered adolescence
uh uh was was a kind of collective IQ of
a small tank of Plankton
um but I suspect it's got better than
that uh the the point being I mean the
point I was making you know I guess the
BBC
uh if it was looking at a news and
current affairs program needs to find an
audience for it and it might well think
that a that a a kind of left liberal
inclined program might be an audience
winner uh and it should my my honest
belief is that it should be allowed to
do that if that's what it wants to do
but not at the same time make the
pretense that it's neutral but the whole
point of the news night uh business is
uh back in 2010 it had an audience of
close on a million you know 900 000 uh
and
Esme and Emily managed to shred that
down to nearly 200 000 across you know
10 years I mean that is astonishing it
is an astonishing
um
degradation of what was the BB's
Flagship current affairs program you
know and and you know we all remember
the good old days of news now my hope is
that they might now be coming back but
it's remarkable that he was allowed to
go on for so long without someone saying
you know aren't we just alienating our
audience with this kind of shriek Fest
um to which you know Esme Ren and Emily
moveless would reply but look at what
our Twitter followers are saying
um which is what the left always does
the left things that Twitter is the
world and undoubtedly they were they
were kind of cocooned in a sort of
bubble both within a new broadcasting
house
but also in a bubble of uh of that kind
of I suppose there's about 200 000 of
them are either people who watch news
night who uh who still watch news9 who
are perpetually on Twitter perpetually
outraged by anybody who ever mentions
the word Tori and Will are relentlessly
active I mean the studies of Twitter
have shown that those people do exist
um so it got it terribly wrong and you
might ask yourself why didn't they stop
it before
but they didn't they they the BBC can
sometimes be very very defensive
well something odd happened I think
during the Corbin years which was that
um people on Twitter uh and that
diminishing section of the public that
watch news night convinced themselves
that the BBC was becoming
um dangerously right wing uh and this is
something you touch on in your column
that Emily matis said recently that it
seems to have been hijacked by a a a
right-wing agenda I mean to any sane
person I think that's just nonsense
isn't it well it's it's not just
nonsense it's hilarious but credit to
Emily but I'm losing just about the only
conservative in the BBC which is Robin
Gibbons on the BBC board
I know about news night
I I've been on it before I've done
programs for a little little
I couldn't tell you that there was only
one person in the entire news United
staff
who voted for brexit you know I mean
that is the level of bias and it I would
suggest it's probably not much different
at the today program world at one and so
on
um
it is incalculably
liberal Lefty I mean to an incalculable
degree uh I don't think it's hard
left-wing uh these are affluent middle
class people who want to keep their
incomes uh when questions of Taxation
come up they often become somewhat less
left-wing than is a two uh
um but it's left wing on particularly
cultural stuff
on immigration on most foreign affairs
but particularly Israel uh and
it's been it's been like that for
decades yeah and it was pretty much like
that when I was there but it became
unapologetically
stridently and brazenly like that at
news night for a period of about 10 to
12 years and you saw what happened as a
result the audience left in absolute
droves
do you think it might be just the
question of journalistic intelligence
rather than bias
um in that the BBC's always had us quite
strong left-wing bias as you yourself
said when you were there there was a
strong left-wing buyers no I don't think
you didn't know I don't think it always
has
oh you don't think
no I think the lesbian bias kind of
uh grew up during the late 80s early 90s
along with the you know it's the it's
the grand scheme marked marched through
the institutions and the change in our
establishment definitely rather than a
right winner he's asking back in the 70s
you could
you could probably say that the the PVC
was kind of a voice of small City
conservatism in many ways and so when
you look at light entertainment within
the BBC back in the 70s all the big
stars Bruce Forsyth Jimmy tabat Malcolm
and why is The Two Ronnies uh all those
all those kinds of people Cilla Black
Richard all of them Tories you know all
of them Tories uh whereas today if you
look at the light entertainment
um if if it's possible by what stretch
of the imagination to call Joe lice at
entertainment now you'll find that
they're all uh they are all tending to
the left uh when they're not actually
claiming to be female uh if they're male
um
what did you think of Joe license uh
much talked about performance on Sunday
on Laura custenburg's new show
well I thought it was exactly what you
would expect from Joe lies that in being
a not funny and being left-win
and that seems to be I I think there
must be an interview room a bit like the
room you're sitting in now uh
after BBC where uh potential comedians
for the BBC are are interviewed and they
say to them uh we just need to check a
couple of things first firstly are you
funny no not at all are you uh someone
who hates a conservative party yeah I
really hated them okay you're in
um because it is remarkable than the
number of Comedians and and performers
who who just aren't funny and I don't
think this is just me they just aren't
funny but they do have the right views
you know and you think of all the great
comedians who don't get on people like
Paul chowdry for example uh is a really
really good comedian and there's almost
never on the BBC despite his videos
uh and DVDs selling out you know selling
masses masses across the country far
more than Joe live service Paul chowdry
uh sold out the uh what do you sold out
something nothing Wembley I think you
know I mean a really big figure and he's
he's not a Jim Davidson he also has a
case too
um or a Roy chubby Brown is a series of
very funny comedian from our ethnic
minorities but because you can't be
pigeonholed by his views the BBC can't
stand it
do you think you talk about a question
of sports in your column is it just a
light the fact that light entertainment
now has to be a bit more political
because the culture wars have taken over
yeah well I think the BBC presumably
thinks that I think the rest of the
country since it doesn't the the
question of sport thing is
it is inconceivable what they did I mean
you know it's just so fantastically
stupid but though it does go along with
that defenestration of Andrew Neal uh
and indeed uh Jeremy Clarkson uh in the
end you know really really popular
people who may have views with which uh
the rest of us here at new broadcasting
has don't share but what they did they
got rid of Sue Barker
and with Sue Barker who was an
incredibly popular presenter incredibly
popular 24 years there they got rid of
Phil toughnell and Matt Dawson who were
the team captains and they had a
chemistry and a Christmas book isn't my
favorite program the only sport I really
like is football
um
uh and there was precious little a bit
on that program uh but they undoubtedly
had a chemistry and they were incredibly
popular they got five million viewers
nearly 5 million viewers they get rid of
Sue Barker they lied to the press and
say that subaka wanted to stand down
which assumka then uh immediately uh
corrected and said I didn't want to
um so they lie about getting rid of Sue
Barker they get rid of Matt Dawson and
Phil Tuttle and Brilliant Paddy McGinnis
and I need to look this up
onia
you know who go come on Google and Sam
quack
some quack
you're in
eight hundred thousand that's how many
people watch it now now in any other
institution or Corporation someone who
made that decision and saw that result
would be sacked
you know they would be sacked I mean
that is a it is a fantastically uh
catastrophic decision to have made and
it also brought odium on the BBC uh with
with Sue Parker
um saying that she felt very hurt and
insulted so it was a massive own goal
rather like the last night of the
problems was an own goal but has anyone
bitten the bullet for it nobody at all
what you're not getting Rod is it's
about the kids
yes it's about the kids they are
perpetually in search
of the 18 to 30 age group
um
but the 18 to 30 age group find them as
irrelevant
and pointless as the rest of us are
beginning to find them uh then you will
not bring it into 13 votes with Paddy
McGuinness and Hugo monya and Sam you
know that isn't Gonna Do It
um you know and that is not really what
their job is you know that has never
been their job their job is to provide
information entertainment you know and
that is that that is the point of their
existence they ought to be looking at
the people who actually pay the license
fee and asking you know
um
uh what do you guys want
instead of taking this
approach which seems to be drawn from uh
Hugh green the previous director general
which is you know we're going to rub
their noses in it we don't care if they
hate it uh we're here to make them
better people that seems to be the point
of view of all the adolescents working
for the BBC
um there's the exception of those
perhaps now in current affairs so it's a
bit of a change of it which is
incredibly welcome
well Rod will stop there but thank you
very much as you know the spec TV
audience skews very highly towards the
18 to 30 demographic
yes it does doesn't it
[Music]
thank you